Il participe en deux ans à deux
albums extraordinaires de
l'histoire musicale du Québec.
Et il y en a eu plein d'autres.
- Si la France a son pompidou,
le Québec a son Robidoux :
Michel Robidoux!
- Le guitariste Michel Robidoux
a fait les 400 coups avec
Robert Charlebois qui,
aujourd'hui, pleure
le départ d'un complice.
(applaudissements)
ROBERT CHARLEBOIS,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Moi, musicalement, c'est
le premier qui m'a offert
une guitare électrique,
une ES-135, la même guitare
Gibson Cutaway d'Elvis.
Donc, je l'ai dans l'épaule
pour le reste de ma vie!
♪ Mes bras te servent d'abri ♪
- Fils du chanteur Fernand
Robidoux, Michel Robidoux
avait la musique dans le sang.
♪ ♪ ♪
Dès le début des années 60,
il a accompagné de nombreux
artistes et composé la musique
de près de 300 chansons, dont
"Le chat du café des artistes"
et "Le petit roi", chansons
écrites et chantées
par Jean-Pierre Ferland.
♪ Dans mon âme et dedans
ma tête ♪
♪ Il y avait autrefois
un petit roi ♪
JEAN-PIERRE FERLAND,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- C'est lui qui m'a montré
à jouer de la guitare,
mais à un moment donné,
je le respectais tellement
que je le laissais jouer
la guitare et je lui demandais
de faire la musique.
♪ Je rêve à Rio ♪
- Michel Robidoux a joué sur un
total de 793 pièces musicales.
Il était l'ami de Claude Dubois,
Raôul Duguay, Stéphane Venne
et Pierre Létourneau.
PIERRE LÉTOURNEAU,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Il pouvait passer cinq heures
en studio avec une concentration
toujours égale.
MOUFFE
- C'était la musique.
Sa passion, c'était la musique.
Il avait toujours une guitare
à la main, il était toujours
en train de jouer, de composer
quelque chose, de fredonner.
C'était sa maîtresse. Sa vraie
maîtresse, c'était la musique.
♪ Passe-Montagne
aime les papillons ♪
- À la fin des années 70,
il va composer des chansons
pour l'émission "Passe-Partout"
en compagnie de Pierre
F. Brault.
♪ Ce soir je fais l'amour ♪
- En 2017, il a signé un premier
album, entouré d'artistes
qui l'admirent, dont
Pierre Lapointe.
PIERRE LAPOINTE,
auteur-compositeur-interprète
- Il a travaillé avec tout
le monde, il a connu tout
le monde, puis il a vu tout
le monde en concert. Et puis,
si je fais le métier que je fais
aujourd'hui, comme je le fais,
c'est en partie parce qu'il y a
eu des gens comme
Michel Robidoux.
♪ Tes lèvres savaient trop
tous les serments décevants ♪
- Malade depuis plusieurs mois,
Michel Robidoux nous a quittés
à l'âge de 78 ans.
- Je suis vraiment tout
à l'envers.
- Repose en paix, Michel.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.